sie haben ihr Ziel erreicht beim Impfen
zumindest 30 Millionen Impfungen das hat
die Regierung als Zielmarke vorgegeben
bis Ende des Jahres nachdem das Boostern
ja zu spät und zu langsam in die Gänge
gekommen ist ja aber jetzt schon was
geschafft 30 Millionen Impfungen kurz
vor Silvester ist diese Zahl also
geknackt
Ostern nach der Weihnachtsgans für
10.000 zusätzlich zum Festessen und
Kirchenbesuch auf dem Programm der
Besuch im nächstgelegenen Impfzentrum
für Bundeskanzler Scholz ein schöner
Triumph erhält damit das
boosterversprechen seiner neuen
Regierung von dem Zeitpunkt an wo die
Impfung aller Erwachsenen möglich
gewesen ist auch tatsächlich 30
Millionen Impfung zu erreichen die
boosterkampagne ist aus Sicht vieler
Experten der Schlüssel im Kampf gegen
das Virus sicher ist die fünfte Welle
kommt fragt sich nur wie gewaltig
[Musik]
und jetzt gucken wir noch mal ein
bisschen genauer hinter die Zahlen und
dann muss ich dann doch ein bisschen
Wasser in den Wein gießen den ganz so
rund lief dann doch nicht über die
Festtage mit dem Impfen da wollte man ja
genau mit demselben Tempo weitermachen
wie vorher aber es gab gleich mal so
rund 30.000 Impfungen pro Tag über die
Festtage und die 80 % Impfquote erste
Impfung die hat man nicht erreicht das
soll jetzt im Januar folgen also das
Wasser in den Beinen jetzt wie sieht's
aus bei den Neuinfektionen aktuell in
Deutschland da sehen wir kleinere Balken
als zuletzt das sind die aktuellsten
Zahlen gerade reingekommen knapp 14.000
Neuinfektionen in Deutschland aber auch
hier Wasser in den Weinen denn stimmen
diese Zahlen überhaupt das
Robert-Koch-Institut weiß es nicht ganz
genau es gab wieder verzögerte Meldungen
über die Tage also man weiß nicht ob das
die waren Zahlen sind und vor allen
Dingen wurde weniger getestet ja über
die Weihnachtsfeiertage also gucken wir
uns mal die wahren Zahlen an nämlich das
ist wichtige Währung der Blick in die
Krankenhäuser wie sieht es da aktuell
aus die
hospitalisierungsinstitidenz ist ja das
entscheidende und da sehen wir
mittlerweile in Westdeutschland ja vor
allen Dingen eine grüne Karte das heißt
da ist die
hospitalisierungsinsidenz meistens unter
die drei wieder runtergerutscht und dann
sehen wir hier noch einen
hotspot-thüringen nach wie vor mit einer
hospitalisierungsinsidenz von deutlich
über 10 also hier ist die Lage in den
Krankenhäusern nach wie vor angespannt
im Westdeutschland hingegen hat sich die
Lage etwas entspannt auch wegen dieser
booster-impfung das wollen wir jetzt
fragen den Virologen Klaus Stöhr der uns
zugeschaltet ist herzlich willkommen bei
Bild live-verstören
ist das dass wir hier auf dieser Karte
schon wieder ja in Westdeutschland grüne
Felder sehen beide Hospitalisierung ist
Inzidenz ein Effekt von 30 Millionen
Impfungen
ja die 30 Millionen Impfungen machen
hier schöne Unterschiede das ist
überhaupt völlig untraglich aber die die
Infektion hat natürlich auch hohe Ebene
stattgefunden die letzten Wochen die
Zuschauer werden sich erinnern waren ja
Inzidenzen in den einigen Bundesländern
von über 500 600 Jahrtausend gewesen
sowas hält eine ein Virus nicht durch
irgendwann gibt's dann keine
empfängliche Menschen mehr die sehen ja
auch auf der Kurve die relativ steil
abfällt dass hier einfach keine
Möglichkeit mehr bestand dass das Virus
weiterlaufen konnte also ist eine
Kombination von auslaufender im
auflaufenden Virus Peak und natürlich
den Bekämpfungsmaßnahmen und dann des
Boostern was jetzt natürlich an Fahrt
aufgenommen hat jetzt kann man so ein
bisschen durchatmen gerade nach
Weihnachten gibt es ein bisschen gute
Nachrichten offenbar von der zahlenfront
und gleichzeitig gibt es diese massiven
Warnung vor Omikron wie schlimm wird das
denn jetzt kommt diese Omicron Wand von
der immer die Rede erst zerstört
kommt auf jeden Fall ist das ist jetzt
glaube ich nicht mal diskutiert aber was
man vergisst in der Berichterstattung
ist dass mit jedem
ommikon Fall wird ja auch ein Delta Fall
wegfallen also wenn jetzt 50 60% der
Fälle tatsächlich durch amerikanische
verursachte und dann fehlen aber auch 50
60% der Delta Fälle und Delta verursacht
ja offensichtlich schwerere Verläufe als
Omegon aber hat eine
höchstwahrscheinlich eine geringere
Übertragung Fähigkeit also hier muss man
auch die Relation dann bewahren und
schauen Sie mal wenn man sich die Zahlen
anschaut die die gerade gezeigt haben
die ja Peak der Inzidenz war ja doppelt
so hoch wie der im Winter gleichzeitig
was sie nicht gezeigt haben aber was sie
die Zahl haben wir ja sicherlich auch
ist die Anzahl der Personen die auf den
Intensivstation liegen vergleichbar mit
der in der winterwelle im letzten Jahr
das heißt wir haben doppelt so viele
Personen die
infiziert sind die positiv sind aber wir
sind asymptomatisch krank und die
gleiche Anzahl auf den Intensivstationen
also das ist zeigt schon wie wie
unterschiedlich die Wellen laufen und es
zeigt doch auf ein Problem was jetzt
sehr schnell zu lösen ist nämlich der
Übergang von der Pandemie zur Endemie
muss auch definiert werden also welche
Parameter welche Indikatoren wird man
sich anschauen um langsam zu Normalität
zurückzukommen in Südafrika hört man
jetzt mit kontaktbeschränkungen auf und
Quarantäne ja das mentale interessant
der Steuer glauben Sie dass das genauso
bei uns kommen wird also das heißt man
muss gar nicht mehr an Quarantäne wenn
man es mit einem omiconfall zu tun
gehabt hat
also man kann ja ebenfalls nichts
garantieren aber das garantiere ich
Ihnen persönlich das wird kommen denn
irgendwann ist es ja so dass die
Normalität einzieht das heißt die
allerhand sind entweder infiziert oder
immunisiert mehrmals dann und dann muss
man die den grenzwertigen Schwellwert
festlegen wo wir zum Normalität
zurückkommt das muss der Expertenrat und
jetzt tun wir können nicht so lange
warten wie jetzt auch ist ja doch keine
Entscheidung gefallen wie man die
serologische Untersuchung der
der genesenen auch bewertet ja das gibt
ungefähr 18 12 Millionen genesene die
jetzt
denselben Status haben müssten
eigentlich sogar noch einen besseren
Status als geimpfte auch das muss man
klären also wie lange wird man
garantieren und kontaktbeschränkungen
aufrechterhalten welche Indikatoren und
Parameter möchte man verwenden um das zu
messen und wann wird man dann zur
Normalität übergehen dass alles das kann
man jetzt berechnen modellieren und auch
dann auch der Bevölkerung mitteilen das
ist ein tolles Ziel was man erreichen
kann also da muss ich noch mal
nachfragen weil das ja eigentlich nach
einer ganz guten sich bei all den ja
immer noch so hohen Zahlen klingt
Omicron sorgt nach all dem was wir
bisher wissen für im Durchschnitt
geringere oder weniger schlimme Verläufe
und mit Omicron könnte dann die
Normalität in unser Leben zurückkommen
möchte ja also omikon ist die Variante
die höchstwahrscheinlich in die Endemie
hinüber führt danach kommt eine neue das
kann ich Ihnen garantieren die wird
genauso wie Omegon und Delta und Alpha
und Wetter vorher sich langsam an die
Menschen anpassen das sehen wir jetzt
schon die Übertragungsrate in dem zu die
Inkubationszeit wird auch langsam kürzer
die hat sich reduziert
endet jetzt denen schon
zirkulierenden indemischen Coronaviren
da liegt die Inkubationszeit bei zwei
bis fünf Tagen dann nähern wir uns die
Übertragungsrate steigt auch das ist
eine Anpassung an den Menschen also es
geht eigentlich alles in die richtige
Richtung Endemie aber jetzt ist es
natürlich noch Winter Infektionsdruck
ist sehr hoch ohne Frage werden sich
alle die jetzt noch nicht
synchronisiert oder infiziert sind auch
das Virus holen höchstwahrscheinlich
schon in diesem Winter viele natürlich
auch erst im Sommer oder im nächsten
Winter aber damit kann man jetzt den
Infektionsdruck sicherlich reduzieren
dass man eben weiter boostet die Leute
die noch nicht die ich überhaupt haben
impfen auch noch erreicht und
kontaktbeschränkung wird es auch noch
weiterhin geben
omegan wird zu einer neuen Welle führen
aber auch bitte dieser großen Diskrepanz
zwischen sehr vielen vielleicht
asymptomatischen Fällen weniger Leuten
auf Intensivstation und die Todesfälle
haben sich auch jetzt halbiert im
Vergleich zum letzten Jahr danke an den
Virologen Klaus Stöhr der und Scooter
und schlechte Nachricht mitbringt hoch
anstecken Omicron diese Wand diese Welle
wird kommen das ist ganz sicher aber er
garantiert ja soweit er das kann dass
die kontaktbeschränkung dann fallen
werden fallen müssen denn sonst ist das
ja alles gar nicht mehr aufrecht zu
erhalten sagt der Virologe Klaus stört
danke dafür ich bedanke mich aber
bei uns im Studio ist jetzt unser
bildmeinungschef Philipp piathoff
Philipp da können wir ja schon fast
sagen danke omicond das es dich gibt
oder dass du Delta ablöst wie siehst du
es also soweit will ich noch nicht gehen
da die Übertragbarkeit von omegonia
deutlich höher sein soll aber natürlich
ist das eine gute Nachricht das hat auch
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach mir
erst vor einigen Tagen gesagt dass
Omikron offenbar zu deutlich milderen
Verläufen führt da könnten wir
tatsächlich aufatmen denn eine
übertragbare Variante also eine Stärke
übertragbare Variante die auch noch zu
schweren Verläufen führen würde das wäre
wirklich nicht so toll nun wissen wir es
um die grauen verläuft milder
und ich habe auch von vielen bekannten
jetzt gehört die tatsächlich über
Weihnachten und Silvester 14 Tage jetzt
in Quarantäne müssen aufgrund von omikon
wegen der Mutation und wenn diese
Quarantäne dann wegfallen würde dann
wäre es auch für alle ziemlich einfach
dann auch alles aufrechzeiten wie Kai es
eben auch schon gesagt hat absolut das
machen jetzt auch mehrere Länder also
Südafrika beispielsweise hat jetzt die
kontaktnachverfolgung und auch die
Isolation von Kontaktpersonen einfach
abgeschafft auch die Briten reagieren
auf diese Omicron Welle die haben dort
ja tatsächlich
rekordinfektionszahlen und anstatt
Maßnahmen zu verschärfen lockern die
gerade die Quarantäne wurde dort von
zehn Tagen auf sieben Tage reduziert das
heißt ganz viele Menschen müssen kommen
früher frei müssen nicht noch länger zu
Hause sitzen und können dann auch dich
wieder arbeiten gehen und kritische
Bereiche der Infrastruktur aufrecht
erhalten jetzt haben wir gerade die
Zahlen aus den Krankenhäusern auch
gesehen da gibt es ein bisschen
mutmachende Zahlen auch eine ganze Karte
von Westdeutschland die wieder grün
geworden ist jetzt habt ihr
herausgefunden viele die dort als Corona
Kranke geführt werden
corona-patienten geführt werden sind
nicht per se corona-patienten die haben
zwar Corona sind aber wegen anderer
Dinge im Krankenhaus ganz genau diese
Zahl die hospitalisierungswerte also
Menschen die mitunter wegen Corona im
Krankenhaus sind die wurden von Bund und
Ländern einfach verfälscht angegeben so
hart muss man es leider sagen
es hieß eigentlich dass nur
corona-patienten gezählt werden müssen
die corona-patienten sind das hat ja
auch der Name die wegen Corona im
Krankenhaus sind fakt ist aber dass sehr
viele Bundesländer auch solche Patienten
gezählt haben die wegen einer ganz
anderen Krankheit ins Krankenhaus
eingeliefert wurden aber zufällig auch
noch positiv getestet wurden und das
Problem ist dass auf diesen Werten auf
dieser
hospitalisierungsinsidenz ja Maßnahmen
beruht haben das heißt die Menschen den
wurde gesagt
die Zahlen steigen in den Krankenhäusern
wegen Corona deshalb müssen wir die
Maßnahmen verschärfen die die Menschen
haben das mitgemacht und jetzt kommt
heraus da wurde einfach alles mögliche
gezählt und die Zahlen wurden künstlich
aufgeblasen die Zahlen wurden überhöht
dargestellt und deswegen wurden auch die
Maßnahmen immer strenger und das haben
wir gestern abgefragt bei den
Bundesländern die haben uns also ganz
viele erfassen diese Zahlen nicht mal
was auch schon wirklich absurd ist aber
diejenigen die diese Zahlen erfassen
sagen unison ja wir zählen
als corona-patienten solche Menschen die
wegen Corona im Krankenhaus sind aber
auch solche die mit Corona im kranken
aber kann man das nicht anders besser
machen ja natürlich man müsste einfach
richtig zählen dass RKI hat der Welt am
Sonntag beispielsweise gesagt eigentlich
sollten nur die Patienten in diese
Statistik mit einfließen bei denen auch
der Krankheitsgrund Corona ist das ist
ja eigentlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit aber die
Bundesländer scheint es
Robert-Koch-Institut offenbar falsch
verstanden zu haben zumindest sagen Sie
uns das ist das was das
Robert-Koch-Institut uns gesagt hat
schaffen wirst und dem gehen wir gerade
nach wichtiger Recherche von euch